en el último vídeo hicimos un argumento
visual para explicar por qué esta
expresión de aquí es menor a un tercio y
ya vimos que esta expresión es
justamente la fracción o la proporción
que hay de osos de todos los animales
que hay en la tienda ahora veremos un
argumento algebraico que yo más bien
llamaría un argumento analítico y para
hacerlo voy a dejar esta expresión a un
lado por un momento y voy a expresar un
tercio de forma parecida a lo que
tenemos que es esta y con la información
extra que tenemos por acá arriba
podremos comparar la así que un tercio
voy a tratar de escribirla como una
fracción también en donde tenga el mismo
numerador que es el número de osos
entonces si yo tengo que es tres osos un
tercio será lo mismo que osos entre tres
veces el número de osos y que esto es
exactamente igual a que si yo sumo tres
veces la cantidad de osos muy bien
entonces ya que tenemos esta expresión
si nos damos cuenta
s mucho se parece mucho a esta que
tenemos de aquí que habíamos obtenido o
bueno que nos dieron inicialmente de
hecho podemos ver que el numerador
coincide y también esté sumando entonces
lo único que nos queda es ver si la suma
de gatos con perros es mayor creo que lo
tape mucho si esta suma es mayor o menor
que la suma de dos veces la cantidad de
osos muy bien y entonces pues te invito
a que desde una pausa al vídeo y pienses
un poco en esto
entonces si los silos si lo secas pues
si en efecto podemos verlo porque aquí
tenemos esta información muy valiosa y
entonces sabemos que el número de gatos
es mayor que el número de perros que en
cualquier caso es mayor que el número de
osos entonces tanto el número de gatos
como el número de perros son mayor que
el número de osos entonces cada uno de
estos es más grande que el número de
osos muy bien entonces si nos fijamos
aquí tenemos de este lado un el bueno
tenemos en ambos lados el mismo
numerador sin embargo aquí tenemos un
denominador más grande un denominador
más grande más grande y aquí es bueno
del otro lado tenemos un denominador más
chico denominador denominador más chico
entonces fíjate tenemos el mismo número
dividido entre dos denominadores
distintos pero este es más grande que
este entonces esto claramente nos dice
que este número de aquí
este número de aquí es una cantidad
menor pues si estamos dividiendo entre
un número cada vez más grande verdad
estamos partiendo en pedazos cada vez
más chicos por ejemplo piensa en un
número el que tú quieras y lo dividimos
en siete partes como es y lo dividimos
en cinco partes pues cada una de estas
partes va a ser más chiquita verdad
entonces justamente este número
este número de aquí
más chico más chico y el otro este de
aquí este de aquí va a ser más grande lo
mismo pasa en nuestro caso que tenemos
de este lado verdad justamente esta
cantidad va a ser menor que ésta así que
a medida que el denominador sea más
grande la cantidad va la cantidad
completa va a ser menor así que
retomando esta expresión esta expresión
va a ser la digamos la más grande en
esta expresión va a ser la más grande y
esta otra va a ser la menor